we have a voicemail number that you can
call any time of day that number is two
one nine two david p here's a really
good practical question about getting
engaged in politics take a listen to
this hi david my name is carlos i've
been trying to call in on the show for a
while and and haven't been successful so
i thought it may be a message and here's
the question another big topic right now
is impeachment some of the most pressing
issues but one of the things that i
wanted to see you cover i wanted to hear
your opinion on is how you think that
people who are somewhat less than
wealthy can enter politics successfully
right you have been interested in
politics for many years and getting to a
point in my career i'm kind of
considering retiring and going into
politics but I'm not exactly Andrew yang
or Tom Styer or somebody else who
already has a whole bunch of right okay
somehow they got cut off I guess he was
going to say a whole bunch of money so
here's the thing this is a great
question to be asking what we actually
we need more people that don't come from
the same three or four industries in
politics but you're right if you are not
in a financial position that is
particularly strong it's going to be
very difficult to become for example a
senator it potentially there are places
as we know people like aoc who without a
lot of money have become elected members
of the House of Representatives but that
is also difficult the best thing to do
is to get involved at the local level
and this accomplishes a lot of things
number one to get on school boards even
sometimes to run for City Council I've
seen people with no money get on City
Council's in different places it doesn't
take a lot of money to do it and it's a
great place to start but it also does
something else that the left has been
failing out I've been talking for years
to anyone who will listen about how the
left has been failing at getting the
bull pen built up getting the farm
League built up and one of the best ways
to do that is by starting to get into
the city councils and the school boards
and all of the other things you can
influence policy yes on a local level
but in ways that do matter to the people
in that community doesn't require the
outsized resources that are often
to run for higher office and it can be
used if your aspiration is eventually
higher office it can be used as a
precursor to start building a a
following building a coalition so that's
what I would encourage you to do I have
no idea where you live and what's
available in terms of government but
there are lots of options you can get on
the board of local non-commercial radio
or television stations that's something
I did back in Northampton Massachusetts
I wasn't on the board of NC TV
Northampton Community Television now
relaunched as Northampton open media
there are limitless options that require
very little money some require no money
whatsoever because these positions are
just open sometimes and you can use them
to get to other positions if that's what
you want so that would be my advice we
will talk on the bonus show today about
stormy Daniels settlement over the
disastrous arrest at that Ohio strip
club this is an old story that we're
following up on we will talk about
cancer cases connected to tap water
contaminants and we will talk about a
town in Ohio that has made Election Day
a paid holiday by swapping it for
Columbus Day which is of course upcoming
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show